natürlich geht es um die kettensägen
affäre um ex
nationaltorwart jetzt jemand die geht
nämlich in die verlängerung wir erinnern
uns am montag ist der ex fußballstar
laut polizei mit einer kettensäge auf
die garage seines nachbarn gestiegen und
hat einen holzbalken durch sieg würde
den blick auf den starnberger see störte
ja kettensägen lehmann selbst erstatten
kurze zeit später tatsächlich anzeige
gegen die polizei weil die vorkommnisse
am freitag seiner ansicht nach falsch
wiedergegeben worden sein ob das
wirklich so stimmt das ist jetzt die
große frage unser reporter jakob male
konnte heute erstmals mit dem nachbarn
von jens lehmann also dem vermeintlichen
geschädigten der kettensägen attacke
sprechen
ich bin hier tatsächlich im
wolkenverhangenen
steinberg am ostufer vor der villa von
herrn lehmann und ich habe heute
tatsächlich mit dem nachbarn reden
können ein älterer herr 91 jahre alte
bauträger und er hat mir erzählt dass
ihr anzeige erstattet hat wegen
sachbeschädigung und
ja es ist wohl so abgelaufen das in
sliema tatsächlich mit einer
kettensäge gekommen ist und den
dachbalken abgesägt hat der ihm seien
seine
sicht versperrt was ich nicht ganz
nachvollziehen kann aber es heißt um auf
jeden fall ist sachbeschädigung
angezeigt worden
jacob das ist aber nicht das einzige was
der nachbar der ja 91 jahre alt ist der
berichtet hat er hat auch darüber
gesprochen dass er angeblich von jens
lehmann bedroht worden sein soll und
dann auch nicht mehr alleine auf seinem
grundstück gegangen sondern in
begleitung der polizei kannst du das
vielleicht noch einmal erzählen ja er
hat mir gegenüber geäußert dass die
polizei quasi vorsorglich ihn begleitet
hat zum auto damit er
möglicherweise jens lehmann nicht
begegnet
es war also eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme jetzt ein konkreter
keine konkrete bedrohung aber zumindest
wollten sie ausschließen dass es zu
einer begegnung kommt
und wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass das
ganze jetzt vor gericht geht das alles
ist ja eine sehr diffuse lage auf der
einen seite randaliert leben anstellt
dann anzeige gegen die polizei da gibt's
jetzt interne ermittlungen und auf der
anderen seite steigt natürlich der
nachbar jens lehmann an gibt es da
irgendwie eine perspektive chance dass
man sagen kann das wird definitiv vor
gericht landen
naja also die geschichte wird vermutlich
schon vor gericht landen weil der
bauträger der
91 jährige hat anzeige wegen
sachbeschädigung
gestellt und jens lehmann ist wohl auch
kein unbekannter was was
gesetzestreue angeht
es kann also durchaus sein dass dieses
dieser vorfall auch vor gericht landet
danke die jako-o
man lehmann das ist das einzige was ein
bei dieser irren geschichte irgendwie
ein feld klar doch das internet da nicht
still steht ganz im gegenteil lacht sich
schlapp hier die besten beispiele
es sind bilder von jens lehmann am
tatort aufgetaucht
lehmanns kettensägenmassaker geht wir
ein twitter-user tom schreibt jens
lehmann wie ich ihn sehe und fahri
kommentiert jens lehmann wenn jemand nur
einen zentimeter von seinem grundstück
betritt manch einer sieht in jens
lehmann auch den mini mann aus der
muppet show und zwei habe ich noch
einmal jens börse ihre garage und dieses
team setzt dem ganzen noch die krone auf
mit bildern aus stephen kings
bescheinigt bekommt lehmann einen mit
tja wer den schaden hat braucht für den
spott nicht zu sorgen
[Applaus]
[Musik]